mais il y a eu le député insoumis du
Nord David Guiraud qui a dit qu'il
n'appelait pas au calme qu'il appelle à
la justice qu'est-ce que vous lui
répondez je trouve que s'il est
responsable c'est inconscient
inconscient dans ces en fait quel est le
but de la France insoumise c'est d'avoir
le chaos dans notre pays c'est d'avoir
d'autres morts dû à ses émeutes le fait
que on demande la justice c'est pas
incompatible avec le fait de demander le
calme et l'apaisement chef de lui sur le
fromage ce n'est pas enfin encore une
fois depuis le début la France insoumise
continue et instrumentalisent c'est les
événements qui peut avoir dans notre
pays et ça depuis 2017 vous savez quand
il parlait du fait de tout ce qui
n'obtiendrait pas dans les urnes il
obtiendrait par la rue c'est aussi une
façon d'attiser d'appeler à
l'insurrection systématique de dans
notre pays c'est aussi un moyen
d'attiser et je ne mets pas sur le même
plan tous les élus de la nups je mets et
qu'effectivement ceux de LSI d'ailleurs
parfois ceux qui habitent dans les beaux
quartiers parisiens et ceux qui ne sont
pas directement confrontés à la
situation des émeutes et de la violence
parce que encore une fois ce ceux qui
habitent dans les quartiers populaires
qui subissent sont nos commerçants se
sont nos agents municipaux qui eux
subissent les violences et les
dégradations
[Musique]